so nightmares are distinctly different
from dreams in the way that people feel
them and experience them so a lot of
people think that a nightmare is
something where someone's chasing them
and you have to wake up screaming yes
that's one of the more common nightmares
that we see is the person is chasing
someone or they're being chased but
really a nightmare just has to evoke
some sort of we call it dysphoric
emotions there's something uncomfortable
you could be sad you could be unhappy
it could be scared anxious but it
traditionally the definition is you have
to be a weight you have to awaken from
this nightmare so you have it if you
awaken from it and you can recall in
detail what just happened that's a
nightmare so it's very different from a
dream where you generally don't wake up
from it and you don't have this
dysphoric emotion there's some debate as
to whether you need to awaken from them
because there are some patients who are
actually starting to say I had these
horrible nightmares but I never woke up
from them but they can still call them
when they get up in the morning so
there's still some debate in the field
when it comes to the reason why we have
nightmares we're still debating that
it's a new area of research nightmares
and the way that I like to think about
it is our brain we have stress during
the day and our brain needs to learn to
process this stress so there are people
who have repetitive nightmares and what
happens is their brain is trying to
process a stress and help their brain
actually deal with what happens if this
stress happens again so their brain is
preparing them to deal with it in case
the stress happens again but it's so
scary that they're waking from it so
they're never actually able to finish
the file and put it away
it just keeps happening because they
awaken from it
so ir 2 imagery rehearsal therapy or ir
two years I'll call it for now it's a
very very simple treatment that was
developed by Barry Krakow in the late
90s early turn of this turn of the
decade
to really help change the imagery that
you're having at night so we think of it
as imagery during the day seeing things
picturing things you had painting a
picture is very similar to imagery at
night
that's what dreams are nightmares
they're imagery at night so what we do
is we take this very simple technique by
basically telling someone if they have a
nightmare so it takes someone who has a
recurrent nightmare of being chased by
someone will have them come in and will
say to them okay now take that nightmare
tell me what it is but now I don't want
you to think about it anymore
just take it almost like it's on a piece
of paper and throw it out change that
nightmare any way you want you can
change a tiny bit of it you can change
the whole thing it doesn't matter and
I'm not the one to tell them how to
change it it's their dream that they're
making so change it any way you want to
make it just it can be neutral it can be
positive whatever so the person chasing
them it could be a very scary experience
what they would do is for example had a
patient yesterday who changed his
nightmare from him to him being chased
who actually having his two younger
brothers chase him around in his old
apartment and they were playing so just
by still having the chasing element but
making it a fun playful chase with two
people he knew made it a much different
dream than the nightmare he was having
so then what I had him do is close his
eyes and I had a picture the story of
his brothers came in they started
chasing him his mom yelled at them to
stop then they stopped for a minute and
then they kept running after each other
he pictured that whole story in his head
painted a picture and could see what
everyone was wearing the smells he could
tell he could see the carpet every
detail and once he took himself through
that picture for about five minutes
practice it morning and night if you
keep doing that it actually helps to
reduce the nightmare frequency because
you're getting control over your
nightmare
for some patients will have that new
dream for others it just reduces the
nightmare frequency we don't know why
yet but it's such a simple technique
because it gives you control over it
over the nightmare
that it works for there have been
studies that show upwards of 90 90
percent of patients who actually do this
treatment actually report it getting
better the nightmare frequency
night terrors are very different from
nightmares a lot of people will think
they're the same but they're really not
night terrors you want to look at the
time of night when you're having the
problem night terrors happen in deep
sleep
nightmares tend to happen in the later
REM sleep so night terrors are in deep
sleep and they're more common in kids as
are nightmares but what happens in a
night terror is it's like a flash we
think of flash of some image or
something happens in the brain we don't
really quite know what and it usually
ends up with the the child screaming
almost like screaming bloody murder it's
very scary for the pair the parents
whoever else is around but it happens
very fast and the child has no
recollection of it they tend to stare
off into space when they're screaming
you can't really engage them at all and
the child will go right back to sleep
afterwards and have no recollection for
it in the morning or very little
recollection usually there's no
recollection it's more scary for the
parents so in kids what we think is
happening in the brain the way I like to
think about it is almost like your brain
is going through all these stages of
sleep and it's developing and children
so fast it's almost like you're shifting
gears in a car and at some point you
actually stall out a little bit and
that's kind of what happens during a
night terror their brains shifting so
fast that it stalls out they have this
episode but then they go back to sleep
and everything regulates itself very
common in kids like I said it tends to
get better as you get older now there
are some night terrors that happen in
adults and if it starts as an adult and
you never had them before then there
might be other things that are happening
there might be anxiety depression stress
and that's when you might have more of a
thorough psychological evaluation and
kids we generally don't attribute to
some attribute to any psychological
basis
and